[Music]
welcome my name is will torres i am one
of the admission officers here at
stanford graduate school of business
i am so thrilled to be joined by our
panelists today
to get us started we're going to be
talking about the entrepreneurial
resources at the gsb
and not so much me talking but we're
going to start with a framework and some
of the different
opportunities here and then we're really
going to get into it with our panelists
so at the gsb it's not just
entrepreneurship
but really how do we develop that
entrepreneurial spirit and approach to
the problems you have in your everyday
at the gsb there's over 60 courses that
have some element of entrepreneurship
embedded into them
um and there's five different pillars
for how we approach entrepreneurship
um looking through the offerings of our
center for entrepreneurial studies
as well as social the center for social
innovation
this comes to life in so many different
ways on campus
uh and today we're going to be joined by
three of our
uh either current students or alumni uh
who can speak to this experience
firsthand
so with that uh
brief intro which we did we knocked it
out let's meet our panelists and then
we'll be spending about
55 minutes together and we're going to
do everything we can to as man
answer as many questions as possible all
right
so let's go ahead and meet our panelists
if we can go
left to right please so jaclyn get us
started um
tell us a little about about yourself
and what was a
memorable course that you took at the
gsd cool
thanks well um hi everyone um my name is
jacqueline chen
i'm dialing in from new york city
um before business school i worked in
financial services
i did invest in banking and late stage
private equity investing
also focus on financial services um i
went to stanford because i wanted to
transition from you know the very
buttoned-up industry
of private equity into launching
something of my own
and to be quite honest i wasn't sure if
i had the gall to really
start my own company but i think bit by
bit and quarter by quarter
um and taking advantage of a lot of the
resources on campus
um i decided after business school that
i wanted to really strike out on my own
and two years later i'm running a seed
stage startup
where 14 people the company is called
benepass
and we help companies administer and
distribute
employee benefits and then jacqueline
one of the questions that i often get
um when folks are applying to the gsb
they're interested in entrepreneurship
did you have an idea what you wanted to
do um like
an idea for that company or business
already or did you just know that you
wanted to lead something of your own
i didn't have a specific idea
i just thought it would be cool to start
something of my own
i'd been reading a lot about startups um
and it seemed like you know people had a
really incredible learning experience
obviously there's a high
uh variability in the outcome but um
you know and there was a path i think in
which i could have stayed in
private equity i wasn't really sure what
i wanted to do
but being at business school i think
really solidified this path for me
thank you shawan
hi everyone i am shawwan my pronouns are
he him and i'm originally from the
suburbs of chicago
before graduate school i spent time in
the dominican republic with an education
non-profit and then did
a couple of years of consulting with
deloitte and i came into grad school
because i wanted to
go back to the nonprofit sector and was
thinking about launching my own
non-profit
and while i was at the gsb i explored an
idea for a non-profit that i
am now building now and leading
full-time called vocal justice
and we empower black and brown youth to
become socially conscious leaders
through a culturally affirming public
speaking program of course that's
memorable that i took at gsb was social
innovation practicum
where it was a forcing function to
actually build out this idea that i had
in my head
where every class the professor said
come in with your theory of change come
in with your
landscape analysis come in with your
metrics for success
and then they brought in guest speakers
from the education space and from the
non-profit space to give us feedback on
that content
and my professor for that class actually
connected me to one of my biggest
mentors now who's a gsb alum who's been
guiding me as i've been building vocal
justice
nice where have there been any um like
moments of feedback or advice that just
like really struck you and had you just
like open your eyes
in a new way oh i'm like how much time
do i have yes
the biggest one that i got was summer
2020. it was the start of the pandemic
and our model beforehand had been me
going to schools piloting this program
and we had a lot of success with that
but my mentor said i know you want to
transition to training teachers on how
to do
this why not do that virtually right now
since everything is virtual
i was really scared about transitioning
to that model too early but
ended up being a huge win for our
organization so we now have
15 educators across the country who
facilitated our program with their
students and were able to go from
working with like 15 to 20 students at a
time to about 200
and now we have this impact with
teachers and students so i'm really glad
my mentor came in and said hey rethink
your model
early on and take advantage of the
hallway that the the pandemic shifted
things so that we can reach more people
awesome ricardo
hi everyone i'm ricardo i am currently
a mba student um will be in my second
year coming up in this
in september um so currently right now
i'm doing an internship in venture
capital at a firm called fintech
collective out of new york city
before coming to do my mba i um
i was a quantitative trader at goldman
sachs and then i went to work at a
at a hedge fund i was running a trading
desk there and then
i also worked at a couple startups and
started tried to start two companies in
the last in my first year at um at
stanford
and um yeah just took full advantage of
all the resources that i could get um at
the university
um through the you know center for
entrepreneurial studies and venture
studios and
and all that i took startup garage my
first year
and also took hacking for defense which
is kind of
uh unreal to take two of the
experiential classes in one year but um
i
i had a ton of fun and frankly those
were the the best experiences that i had
just learning from people who have been
through this
you know time and time again and and
meeting a bunch of people that are
you know have a lot of um you know
interesting ideas about how the future
should look and
and you know trying to be kind of a
driver for that so
um yeah look forward to uh speaking with
you all
nice and then earlier you mentioned you
tried um you were
like trying to launch a few things at
the beginning you're doing vc now how do
those pieces
fit together how have you evolved over
your time at the gsb so far
yeah so i think for me venture doing
doing an
internship in venture capital was a way
for me to meet more entrepreneurs talk
to more individuals who are starting
companies and
and really get a feel for um you know
how they work how they think
how they make decisions how they uh you
know think about the problems that
they're trying to solve
and it's been great i've i've i mean in
the time that i've been doing this i've
probably chatted
like no joke with like 100 different
founders and
um that that experience is you know has
been super beneficial and i think
for me it's really about trying to
i don't know go down one or one of two
paths either a try to find a way to make
venture capital industry more beneficial
for founders who are trying to
start good companies or b um
like really find something that i'm
passionate about and just dive into that
right nice i have a feeling um kind of
finding something that you love and
really diving into it might be a theme
in some way shape or form over today's
conversation so
i'm gonna stop sharing that way we can
focus on each other
for our attendees please feel free to
already start popping your questions
into that q a box
i will be interspersing them throughout
the session and then really diving into
that q a box towards the end
um don't forget that there is that up
boot up vote
uh so if you see a question that you
also want to see answered go ahead and
click that and that'll help that rise
through the list
okay so as we're talking about the
entrepreneurial resources
um startup garage and the experiential
element of it uh
starting with maybe some of the folks
who took it can you tell us a little bit
more about startup garage and what that
was like
i can i can start or um
so so i did i did an unusual route of
taking startup garage in my first year
so um we weren't allowed to take it as
first years in the fall
quarter so i did the winter quarter and
i was able to do that because
i had started the company that i was
working on before even coming to the gsb
so i already had some traction and we
had to put together a deck and
everything to
to display that that was the case um so
there is
there is an application process if
you're going through oh actually
either way there's an application
process but there's an application
process you
put together um effectively what you
know a deck
which is very very similar to what you
would show to you know a venture capital
firm if you were
trying to raise capital at the time
right um
though it's you know lower stakes in
some sense maybe but um
you do get a lot of help from the um
startup garage community to
you know help you put that together once
you get into the course
series of 10 weeks you get matched with
a partner
or an advisor our advisor was like an
awesome individuals like the
ex-cmo of ebay and just like incredible
people that we were matched up with
you get matched up with like an
operating person to help you on the
operating side and a person to help you
from the teaching team who also the
individuals that are on the teaching
team are just like incredible
experienced
individuals as well and then you go
through the process of the
like lean startup methodology right you
go you create hypotheses
you do tests to uh test them out the
school provides resources
we we you know ran a couple ad campaigns
for example that we got resources from
the school to
pay for um we went through and
you know built our prototypes and talked
to a ton of people and got feedback and
and um and it was really taken seriously
i think that the
the the period the whole intention of
that class is really to just
get you to start something for real and
connect you with people who are going to
help you be successful
and then jacqueline you took startup
garage as well i did
um i was a bit more of a late bloomer um
so i took startup garage
my second year i took for the first
quarter in the second quarter
um and i i think you know what's great
about startup garage is that it's a mix
of folks in terms of whether or not
you're 100 sure you're going to start
something of your own so i think
you know in my team of four people that
i took the class with
um two people joined early stage
startups after business school
and one person did um went into venture
um and then i'm of the four the person
who went on and actually start something
um and so i think what's great about
that class is that you get a mix of all
those
like it's a big class and so everyone
has like a slightly different
orientation and so on one end of the
spectrum you have folks who just want to
understand what that lean methodology is
on the other hand you have folks who 100
knew like ricardo maybe that like he
want
he had a specific idea in mind um and
wanted to focus on that
um so that was a really great experience
for me second year
to kind of solidify some of the early to
undo kind of what i had been trained in
which is like very
process driven very buttoned up very you
know
all of your eyes and cross all of your
t's to a start-up mindset of
you just try something you throw it on
there in the world you get some feedback
you fix it you try it again rinse and
repeat
um with a much higher like feedback loop
and so kind of unorienting myself from
like a previous
mode of operation to this new to this
new or scrappier
side um is is a bit of a transition or
at least it took for me it took a little
bit of time to get comfortable with that
yeah and so so you mentioned some of
your original groupmates now they're all
doing different things so
one question i often get is what if i
not sure i want to
be an entrepreneur but i want to take
the classes how welcoming
is it a for folks who are interested in
the field
but also for folks who might be dabbling
or there to learn like how can you talk
can you tell us a little bit about that
mix
i think startup garage is very friendly
to everyone across that spectrum
and frankly people change part way
through so i would say
one um you know one of my classmates i
think he was
he i think he could have been 50 50 and
then just decided ultimately like he
didn't have you know one specific idea
he didn't have like one
um specific it wasn't it didn't feel
like at the right time in his life
to start something but he still i think
you know has
has in the back of his head that he'll
do it eventually um so i think startup
garage in particular is very welcoming
to that
there are other resources um other
similar classes to startup garage in the
d
school and in the engineering school um
that are called either
lean launch pad or launch pad they're
confusingly named very similar things um
but those are a bit more intense if you
will um
and uh and i think for folks who are
like very
very focused on it but i would say
startup garage is very friendly to
any from light interest to heavy
interest yeah i i would i would
very much agree with that i think that
um it's
it's like anything else in the world
it's kind of like you get out of it what
you put into it type of situation and
um i think a lot of people go into the
process
looking for team members who you know
will work well together
and even if they don't necessarily all
agree on the idea or
they don't all have an idea to pursue i
think the part of the process is to
learn how to work well in a team in an
entrepreneurial environment
and um just you know follow whoever
becomes the
the de facto leader in in you know
pursuing that idea
and i think a lot of people have been
very amenable to that and the teaching
team
is um you know recognizes that not every
you know uh um uh group that's in the in
the in the class is going to go off and
you know raise funds and become become a
startup um so they
they curate the content to make it very
um
very accessible for um you know folks
who are going to end up being in a
either at a venture capital firm or in a
corporate setting but like want to have
that entrepreneurial
sort of you know drive as well
while we're on the topic of experiences
and courses
uh show on there's a question from marco
here about
um kind of prioritizing opportunities
especially if you're thinking about
taking classes from other places on
campus i know you talked a little bit
about
you know that intersection of education
um can you can you share a little bit
about how you approached that
yeah so i coming into gsb know i wanted
to do one of two things afterwards it
was either
an existing education nonprofit or start
my own
so i decided to prioritize classes that
would help me do that
i personally wasn't looking to explore
that many other topics outside of
education and social justice in terms of
issue area and so classes that were
specifically speaking to that got to the
top of the list for me
and then the other choice that i made
around prioritization was around skill
set so
a lot of students in my class were
asking this question should i focus more
on the heart or technical skills or
should i focus some more of the soft
skills like
communication and team management and i
recognized that my bread and butter was
not going to be crutching numbers
doing financial analysis and that i just
needed the fundamentals when it came to
that so
i leaned more into classes that were
about how can you hire well how can you
make sure you have equity in terms of
your company culture and how can you
actually manage your team especially in
a remote setting
since i knew that might be an option for
for vocal justice so
i ended up doing lots of education
non-profit work and the soft skills
classes while i was at gsb
nice and then there's a lot of really
interesting questions there's a lot of
interest in that startup garage
experience and a lot of the
kind of experiential places on campus
like
how would you talk about the timing of
them um
would you do that early on do they come
later in your second year
i know there's a couple different paths
here and then also what what's typical
at the gsb can
someone share a little bit maybe
jacqueline since you referenced it first
like
what that timeline could look like for
folks yeah
um so startup garage is commonly taken
your second year in the fall
quarter um that's the biggest class and
then should you choose to continue
um you can continue on into winter
quarter
and then some overachievers like ricardo
can get in winter quarter without having
done the fall quarter
um which which is definitely option but
is um is less common
um and then i believe the engineering
schools
uh lean launch pad is in the winter
quarter and then the d
schools launch pad is in the spring
quarter um
those two classes are more by
application and you have to have
a team and have some demonstrated uh
not traction but demonstrated
experimentation
already happening so it does take some
pre-planning to apply
in order to have a successful
application um to those two classes
and then in the summer i did something
called entrepreneurial summer program
whereby i
interned at a seed stage company it was
10 people in a room um and
uh stanford supported part of my
compensation for the summer to enable me
to work there
so that's a summer program and i think
there's lots of other resources
year-round as well thanks ricardo or
shawan for
for courses that do involve um a group
did you know the people on the outside
what are what are some different ways to
help you meet people
uh who might you might be able to work
well with
sure i can speak to that um so the i was
looking at courses that were in the
social innovation space and the
center for social innovation hosted lots
of mixers too many to keep up with
at the the start of the year where you
show up to the event you would actually
get different stickers to represent
issue areas that you were passionate
about whether it's
education or youth development or
healthcare put those stickers on and
then network with other people that way
and then through some of those events
you might meet people who want to
support you with your venture or take a
class with you
and then when you're enrolled in some of
the social innovation classes they'll
send out a spreadsheet with
ideas that people have and then
facilitate introductions for you if you
want to get connected to other people
and then if you can't find a group of
people to work with within your class
you can always talk to the professor and
pursue your own thing alone and they're
really supportive of that
which is what i ended up doing in my
social innovation practicum course
nice there's a question here from kiwi
and shawn earlier you mentioned knowing
that um
like crunching numbers was not
necessarily going to be
uh your skills your like bread and
butter
um and as you think about like some of
the core
experiences and skill sets that a leader
needs it's like understanding your own
needs versus
what what things people on your teams
can do
and this is a question for all three of
you um
what are what were some skills that you
felt really
comfortable with and what were ones that
you were looking
for others to contribute and you know
how did you either discover that
was it trial and error did you already
know from the outset and
anybody can jump in on this one
yeah one one thing i would say is um
just a general sense of like drive to
understand the entrepreneurial process
was like important
um just generally for people to be
bought into the experience
i think that was um that's important and
that was reflected immediately if you
met somebody that was at one of these
team formation events there's a good
chance that they're trying to figure
that out
um and then kind of you know it through
discussion in those events you get
you get a sense of um of uh you know
how much bought into into the idea they
are uh the other thing i would say is um
around like complementary skill sets
that was super important as well
so like i have a certain type of skill
set and i was looking for individuals
who are kind of like the opposite of me
right because it doesn't make sense for
me to look for folks that are more of me
uh to some extent and that that end up
working up really well for the team that
i had for startup grudge i'm not like
the most organized person but my
um you know the the partner that i had
for uh for startup garage just probably
could be like an amazing logistics
expert
or something right but um so that ended
up working out really really well
um i would say like the traditional
answer i think is to
you know to put it very bluntly business
people want to find an engineer
like that's that was like the common
trope if you will
um among you know founders and i guess
the gsp class
um you know i attempted to at stanford
didn't work out for me but ultimately
like the peop like my two technical
co-founders
at benepass are people through my gsb
network so one was in my pass down house
my second year he was the only non-gs
beer in our house
um and then the other uh other guy
kabir i met through a gsp who had known
him from a previous life so
i think there was there are some people
who felt pressure i guess to find the
perfect person
to like partner with and be a co-founder
with while on campus
um and i certainly felt that pressure
and but it kind of worked out for me
after the fact as a result of the gsb
network um
so that's kind of like additional
perspective
i would provide there in addition to
what ricardo said obviously you want
people who are like
more and who are interested and aligned
with kind of what you want to put
into the class um some of the classes
uh i think in particular the engineering
version of it and the la
and the d-school version of it basically
everyone has to like really commit this
is going to be your top priority that
quarter
the same isn't necessarily true of
startup garage although
you could you know want to put yourself
in a group where all four of you kind of
are aligned on that point
um but that's a bit more on the i guess
soft side as opposed to like hard skills
assembling
yeah um and you you mentioned something
really interesting jaclyn the network
and so thinking about kind of we're
talking a lot about the
resources during your time at the gsb
but your career
and whether you start entrepreneurship
immediately after or down the line or
you pivot around a couple different
places
that's like a lifelong path um so
maybe starting with shawan and
jacqueline like now that you're out
how the like the stanford network um
like supported you in this endeavor and
then ricardo as a current student are
you
experiencing that as well and like how
are the outside
kind of post-gsb um
family members helping you out so maybe
we can start with shawan since
yeah yeah so i i'm grateful that i have
a fellowship through this
um center for social innovations social
innovation fellowship
that supports early stage social
entrepreneurs
and through that i get a coach who works
for the center for social innovation
and i meet with her every two weeks to
walk through my idea and so
um that's been incredible as i'm
building an organization hiring my first
employee to have
somebody who's affiliated with that that
team to just give me real
proton feedback and be a sounding board
for me and then the alumni network is
also incredible i have not
tapped into it enough because i'm still
breathing after graduating just a few
months ago but
i know that there are tons of listservs
with entrepreneurs affiliated with a
venture studio at stanford that
you can blast out to if you need advice
on anything as the emails coming into it
all the time
um and so as i'm getting ready to do
fundraising in the future
and building out the organization more
i'm definitely going to be code emailing
a lot of gsb alum and
i've heard from friends that um the
response rate is really high when you um
contact somebody from from the network
um yeah um gsb network is very strong in
my
entrepreneurship life i think had i not
not gotten
gone to the gsb i don't think i would
have ended up down this path
um i would say in terms of
kind of date so my co-founders aren't gs
beers but like i said i met them through
my gsb network like one connection
removed
um i am in a kind of a ceo support group
among founders um in our class and all
of us have
um some of us are doing like mentor back
startups other folks did search funds so
kind of the
you know different types of the
different flavors of entrepreneurship
that will had
uh mentioned earlier on the slides um
and then
in addition uh i you know i've also
taken venture funding from folks in the
gsb network
um you know several classmates are on my
cap table
um so there's like kind of that
financial support um as well
um and so i yeah definitely there's
there's
the network brings so much or has
brought at least so much to my
experience with entrepreneurship um that
you know it's
it's everywhere and it's um it's
definitely
uh been a huge help to date
yeah and i would just say like during
during the
you know while you're a student it's
still like massively impactful i would
say the
the the reason i have the internship i
have is because of a mba 2 that was
you know the intern the previous year at
the same firm and you know the
connections that i had through them and
like the
the kind of uh insight that i had about
the firm and kind of you know the
the process and the people and
everything that was shared through um
through having that person in my network
and then in addition to that i would say
it's it's just you know having being at
the gsb
especially in the time that you're there
um uh to shawan's point earlier like the
response rate that you get on emails to
individuals that you reach out to is
like
incredibly high right so of you know
150 emails that i sent out to vcs i got
i
had chats with like probably 50 of them
right which is crazy and some of these
are partners at you know really
really important firms and um those
those experiences are what have allowed
me to be able to
um you know have the insights that i
have now really right um so without that
it would be
very difficult to have done that with
you know without having had a background
inventor or entrepreneurship before
coming to the gsb
yeah i think we're we're kind of
alluding to this already
but um maybe if we can distill even
further
um and take a moment we're going to jump
into the q and a box there's a question
here from chanyeon
about comparing like if you were to go
into entrepreneurship without an
mba um how does your gsb
experience bring some unique values or
kind of
um perspectives to like the things that
you're interested in
so take a moment
versus no mba or
like with a um now the gsb experience
like how do you think it's different or
where's the value in pursuing the mba if
you're thinking about going into
entrepreneurship
this is for anybody on the panel
um i can kick it off um so a couple
things come to mind
uh first i think that stanford teaches
entrepreneurship in a way that's about
the process
as opposed to about a specific idea and
i think that is something
that was a mindset shift um
that was pretty strong for me because i
always thought oh these people started
accompanying because they had one
specific idea and until i got to
betterpass i've recycled
there were of many many many great a
graveyard of ideas if you will
um and this one worked out because of
the series of you know
testing talking to customers prototyping
that whole process
um and i think again you can probably
read a book
and understand it's not rocket science
um but at the same time getting to put
it into practice with mentors along the
way
is the value of being in a school
environment
um and then the second thing i'd say is
that around like the network you know
kind of already touched upon that
already um
and that's that's a huge help
to like building your business over time
um and then after a certain point and i
feel like i'm currently making this
transition now
is we are a seed stage company we're
gonna
grow and now my job has quickly
transitioned from being just a
scrappy early stage get things done as
quickly as possible to
transitioning to be a leader of my
company and there are a lot of things
that i mean i'm not making the
transition perfectly but there's lots of
those are different jobs and different
functions um and so i think a lot of
entrepreneurs
perhaps without their mba can kind of
chance into it because they have a great
idea and it just starts taking off
but you might not have the foundational
skills around how to be a good leader
how to be a good communicator how to
build team morale
all these things are really crucial to
make your company become
a bigger company that's gonna you know
that's gonna stand the test of time
um and so that fi that final piece of
the skill set is absolutely something
that you
that i learned at stanford and continue
to put into practice
um and i don't think i would have i mean
again i could read a book but i don't
think it would have
sunk in as much as it did had i not gone
to the gsb
see lots of head nods from the panel
yeah
i would just add to that that um i i
think that
the sort of like
being able to have the time to test and
try things out
was super critical right so like you're
spending two years here that you would
otherwise be spending at work or
whatever and you'd be
super busy i i can't tell you how
how much time i've had to be able to
reflect on you know kind of myself
and the experiences that i have and also
try a lot of different things out in
different industries and
you know different areas of knowledge
that i wouldn't have had
time to to explore before and i think
what that does for the entrepreneurial
experience is really just allow you to
do that testing without you know kind of
any uh
unforeseen kind of losses or potential
losses and
um allows you to jaclyn's point to kind
of
really really understand the process and
not really you know have to be focused
on
on the um the idea itself generally
and add two things to that one there's a
joke at gsb that everybody
has been a startup founder is thinking
about being one will be
one one day and so you're just
surrounded by people who understand that
world which for me was really helpful to
build my confidence when it came to
to pitching there's so many of my
friends who are saying oh you should ask
for even more money for yourself for the
organization
and this is how you tactically can go
about doing good because they understand
what it's like to put yourself out there
and
the importance of making a big ask and i
think because i learned that from people
who are part of this entrepreneurship
world
it helped us to secure more funding for
for the organization
and then the the second piece is
building on what ricardo was saying that
not only do you have the the space to
reflect on ideas but you also can get
some funding to do so
the center for social innovation has a
fellowship called the impact design
immersion fellowship
for people who want to explore ideas in
the social innovation space
between their first and second year at
gsb and i did that fellowship and got
um funding thankfully for 10 weeks to
explore this idea
talk to students about their experience
connect with with school leaders and
that was awesome just to learn more
about it and that's not something i
could have done if i were working
full-time both because i didn't have the
time to do it or or the money to support
it
hey there's a question here from aditi
we've
focused a lot on kind of experience
and i my suspicion is most of
your work is here in the us kind of
domestically
um but maybe it's in other experiences
or things that your classmates have done
are there resources for people looking
at startups aiming to address
issues in other countries um any
insights on that would be would be
awesome
well first and foremost i think like the
the package that you
you get when you come if you say that
you have a startup and you're a stanford
student
from the um stanford venture studios
you know is blind to where you're
operating you know just first and
foremost
and um all of the resources that they
put through for example like connecting
you to lawyers or accountants and
things like that they often will make a
point to do
things for specific industries in
specific regions so they would do things
for
social innovation for example
specifically but then also for
international
um things as well so they do have some a
lot of content that they cater
specifically for
um for that
has anybody seen like maybe classmates
trying to launch things internationally
or
you heard anything from on from that
front
yeah there's um there's a company from
my class called ajib
uh which is a robo advisor in indonesia
um i think overall like it's a process
not the idea and that also applies to
whether it's u.s or international
at the end of the day you're trying to
solve a problem or you know a pain point
as it's called
um and that exists everywhere in many
different forms
um so it's more about the process as
opposed to you know a specific idea
okay and so kind of on that similar
theme of
process versus idea can you are folks
able to apply the process to an idea
they had before the gsb
in some of these classes or are these
ideas that had to have come up
at the gsb
it can definitely be something you have
before gsb or came up with with
gsb i had my idea a similar version
before
actually when i was applying to gsb i
remember writing about in my application
and
then when i got to gsb i just started
exploring it through coursework
other people set up weekly chats with
friends to just brainstorm a ton of
ideas and then decide which one they
want to explore
while they're there
um my friend my friend chad monroe from
my class
runs startup called jupiter with two of
our classmates now
uh when he first got to campus i think
the original format of this idea was
shipping things from uh the us
outside via to bring goods that like
weren't otherwise accessible
um outside the us and now it's a
last-mile grocery delivery company and
that evolution kind of took place while
we were at the gsp
um in in rue he got you know two other
gsb co-founders and an engineer
um from an undergrad i think um so
anyway
all the all that is to say like you can
definitely start
you know early bring bring people along
look for people to join you on your ride
your idea will probably change
and you know international or us i think
that's all the world is your oyster
question about funding so getting
resources
and funding is going to be a big part of
the entrepreneurial journey
um there's a question from joshua about
resources to help you pitch to venture
capitalists for seed funding
um any experiences on that front
i i mean i would argue that this the
winter quarter
startup garage is designed to make you
help you
design your pitch deck like that's
that's the
the unsaid kind of you know intention
and
at the end of that um that class you do
actually get to pitch
live to to a couple of venture
capitalists that are invited by the
teaching team
and when i say a couple i don't mean
like two or three i mean there was like
10 of them there
right so like and they're all very
related to your um
you know your the area that you're
looking to raise from and and
from that class or how there have been a
lot of people who have gone forward and
raised capital
the same experience i had the same exact
experience in the um
in hacking for defense uh at the end
bunch of people pitched
some people actually got funded right so
um that the resources are there
and same thing with stanford venture
studios throughout the year they'll put
put out a lot of
um resources that you can go and look at
yourself to go look at
you know examples and walk-throughs and
things like that but you can also sit
down
with um a vc or an entrepreneur and go
through your deck
we did that you know on multiple
occasions and and
got a ton of good feedback from uh from
individuals
and shawan you mentioned you were
talking about a mentor
um ricardo you mentioned a mentor in one
of your other classes
do these kind of relationships come up
organically are they mostly
um things that come through structured
formats and classrooms how have you seen
um mentorship advisor sponsor
relationships kind of develop across
campus
yeah for me it was pretty organic my
professor reached out and said hey i
wrote a book about founders of
nonprofits do you want to connect with
this one and i said yes of course i do
and
we had a call we hit it off and then he
sent me a really kind email afterwards
and so
i was like okay this person seems
incredible his name is reid soros and
i wanted to to learn from him since his
nonprofit has done great work in the
education opportunity space and so i
just asked him hey do you want to be my
mentor for the summer while i'm
exploring this idea
and he agreed and then we just continue
working together from there
i think other people might do some code
emails to find mentors in a more
a more formal sense but for me it was
just organically talking to people and
then see who you connect with and going
from there
yeah i i um so there is there are formal
processes for it in
um that i went through and uh started
garage and hacking for defense where you
get matched up with a mentor
though those are are also hit or miss
just like in in normal life if you go
out and try to find a mentor it can work
sometimes and sometimes it doesn't
um we were fortunate that one of the one
of the
folks that was one of our mentors was
amazing and we hit it off and
you know the the sessions were great but
we you know there were examples when
that wasn't quite the case and then
so there are a lot of um you know
examples
uh that are more structured but there
are you know to shawan's point
um i i actually did probably the person
who's helped me the most is somebody
that
i reached out to via cold email um you
know that per
you know i talked to a whole bunch of
people but that person was the one that
i connected with the most and i just
kept
you know having more questions for and
kept connecting with
and they agreed to and they provided all
sorts of guidance and
things like that and i think it's it can
happen very organically as well just
as part of you know if you're willing to
be coached you'll find someone
jacqueline here's a question for you how
did you think about the cost of the mba
so we're taking a
whole left turn here um kind of coming
back to the beginning of the journey
but how did you think about the cost of
the mba
including opportunity cost of leaving uh
lucrative career you know finance
in the context of wanting to start a
company like how did you kind of
approach that mentally yeah um
i'm not doing a startup because i think
it's gonna make me a ton of money i mean
that would be great as a side effect but
uh the
reason i'm doing it is i think it's the
best conduit for personal and
professional growth
um you know the actual content you know
i deal with irs rules on taxability
benefits when i was five years old i did
not dream that's not like going to space
you know that was not my dream
um but the lessons learned along the way
are like why i wanted to do it to start
with and that's
what sustains me when things get really
tough
and you know your first five or ten
customer calls and they tell you
your idea is not great or they would
never buy it or whatever it is like i
think that's that's what sustains me
through it
um so i didn't think of starting a
company
as like a in the in the rational way i
would say that you're presenting it
that way it was never for me about that
um i i think even if i had taken the
money i invested in my mba
and said i'm going to put in a bank
account and start spending that money
i don't think i would have had a clue on
how to actually do that in a good way i
mean
like i said i didn't have an idea i
didn't have a process i didn't have a
co-founder
and so those are other very important
ingredients other than money
for really to start something of your
own um
so i guess i yeah my answer is like
i didn't think about it in that way and
um you know while i
if you have a fully fleshed out idea and
all you really need is capital to make
it work yeah i mean i i think
you can make the case for that but for
me it was about getting the other
ingredients
um for starting a company
and here's a question from michael um
thinking about
opportunities to continue working or
launching something outside of the
classroom during the academic year
is that possible how do you juggle your
time
were you continuing to work on your
ideas
outside of the classroom like after
those classes have been over
yeah definitely go ahead yeah sorry yeah
certainly um i think it's it's it's kind
of you know you
you manage your own time the the way
that you want to and you kind of
prioritize things as as you see fit
right i think you you you
are advised not to work at
a startup while you're in um while
you're doing your
uh your mba but there are people that do
it right so you people have done it and
like
they have great experiences and and kind
of learned a lot and have a lot of
personal growth
and then there's tons of people that are
working on ideas whether they're doing
it through coursework or not and they
spend a lot of time
outside of school doing that and being
around your
classmates helps um quite a bit in terms
of like
you know breaking down barriers that
that you're facing
and and all that as well
yeah that hits on a lot of what i was
going to bring up it it's hard
to to work on your idea and also be a
student and have a social life
um but i think if you come in and you
say this is what i want to do and i know
i'm committed
to at least exploring the idea you block
the time on your calendar before
somebody else sends you an
invite for for an event and for me it
was worth it i
i said no to a lot of stuff at gsb so i
could be off campus going to schools and
pilot
my idea but i'm in the long run in line
with what i wanted to do out after gsb
and i still had time to like make good
friends and have fun and and all of that
so it's not like you you sacrifice
everything you just have to be a bit
more intentional
the other thing is that there are a lot
of classes where you can work on your
venture and do things for the class so
basically any class that i was in i
found a way to tie to vocal justice so
i was in winning writing that was a
communications course i would have my
pitches be about vocal justice
or my non-profit management class i
would do research on a competitor that i
needed to research anyway for vocal
justice
and so it ends up being less work in the
end
since you have a dual purpose for it and
then schwann did you do
a low key note as well yes i did a low
keynote which is a nine minute talk on
the issue you care about and mine was
related to vocal justice it was
on public speaking and critical
consciousness and i use that now to
promote the organization
these are also accessible so if you go
to youtube and search low key notes you
can also see what that looks like so
encourage folks to take to check that
out as well
then jaclyn did you pop off did you have
a nope
nothing awesome and so we're talking
about like
intentionality with time i think that
can also be an intentionality with
opportunities
um and the question from jay is like how
did you
balance you know driving towards that
idea versus
staying open and exploring like other
things like any advice to someone who's
grappling
with those same that same tension
i think by being around classmates who
are doing
lots of different things it comes you're
by now
like by default kind of open just from
you know dinner
like lunchtime dinner time conversation
what's like what's everyone interested
in what's everyone focused on and so
you'll just learn by default a lot of
what other pursuits could look like um
so i guess for me uh i
i felt like it was very clear like what
the different flavors of and if anything
i could draw inspiration from my
classmates of like how they were
pursuing it in their way
um that gave me ideas on like you know
how i might inform my own process
nice one thing i would just add there
quickly is
that um as long as you're committed to
sort of either being an entrepreneur or
joining a startup i think
things become way easier because if
you're also trying to recruit for like
um consulting and pe then things become
more difficult because you're basically
recruiting the entire
year but if you commit to kind of being
either an entrepreneur or going to work
at a startup
then you have a ton of time to explore
right you don't have to commit to
something immediately or if you do
commit to something
for a month and you decide to pivot at
the end of that
then it's not a waste of time because
you still have more months to go right
so i
i wouldn't be too concerned about that
it's more just making the decision
between
am i going to go the traditional kind of
consulting pe route or am i going to go
the
entrepreneurship startup route
and we're getting close to time and so
i'm going to go ahead and claim this
last
question as you're thinking you know
words of wisdom to a younger you whether
it's in the application process it's
during your time at the gsb
maybe it's just as you graduated as
you're
venturing out onto this whole new whole
new brave world ahead
like what advice would you give to
yourself
um so take a moment and then maybe
ricardo we could start with you and john
then jacqueline
to take us home
yeah i would i would say i mean first
and foremost like breathe
right it's like a it's it's a it's a bit
of a long process and it's
super fun it's really transformative
from a personal
and uh you know educational perspective
um you're gonna meet a ton of
amazing people who you never thought you
would be kind of rubbing
rubbing elbows with and stuff but um
just breathe for now and
just know that you know the the world's
going to be your oyster once you're here
you're going to have tons of
opportunities to meet people
um have conversations you never thought
you'd have and you know
learn topics that you never thought
you'd kind of be diving into
thank you show on i would say
take time for yourself and i think there
are two ways to think about that one is
just time for you to breathe relax binge
watch that show on netflix because the
entrepreneurship journey
is hectic and so you got to just take
that time and be diligent about taking
care of yourself but
the the other way i think about that is
time for introspection
i think a lot of my best thinking comes
when i'm just sitting by myself for a
couple of hours and
free writing about why i'm doing the
work that i'm doing what my values are
what some of my concerns are and how i
want to get better
and it's really hard to make that time
on your own if you're just go go go with
your
your venture and so being diligent about
having that time maybe every two weeks
every month
um to have some introspection i think is
important
awesome and then jaclyn taking us home
uh well the first uh ricardo and
chawan's answers were both really good
uh
you know it's all gonna be fine um i
would say
uh have a plan and be patient
um so i think for me you know having a
few
areas of focus um help me make
really easy not easy but like easier
decisions given just the
wealth of things you could be doing at
the gsb and
you know your calendar will be booked
end to end and probably double book
because there's so many cool things that
you want to be doing
um and so you need some level of focus
of like what
you know what you want your experience
to be oriented around
you know a small a few things um and and
really spend time on those two things
um and then finally i would say you know
i think one
sense of feeling i had was like oh i see
so and so doing this and that's really
taking off
i see so-and-so doing this and that's
really taking off and
i think in hindsight um you know having
a bit more patience with myself that
like you know for me my entrepreneurship
journey bloomed kind of post business
school and
i wasn't one of the ones that kind of
came in um with a clear vision in mind
um but it still kind of you know worked
out the way that it was
meant to work out so be patient and have
a plan
wonderful so breathe take time for
yourself
be patient have a plan these are all
really really wise words to live by
definitely stuff that i'm gonna be
applying to my own life even though i'm
not in
entrepreneurship at the moment but with
that thank you
so much to our panelists who took your
time out today to
to spend with us for those of you in the
audience if you haven't done so already
i would
definitely encourage you to jump onto
mystanford.mba
you can create a dashboard there and
with a few questions
we'll be able to help collect ideas
events that might be of interest to you
speaking of events beginning of august
august 2nd
through 6th we are hosting an
application week to help you better
understand the process
and so in doing that to help you put
your best foot forward
uh there was some a lot of themes about
process
and hopefully that is one place that
we're going to be able to dig into that
even more deeply
with that thank you again for joining us
and we hope to see you across
other events this summer stay safe um
hope to see
you